hachimura doesn't get the roll westbrook
again is there leaves it off for len for
the dunk what an effort
by russell westbrook i love it
beale is pull up gets hit and he's got a
chance for a three-point play
the outcome to be a little different jk
shot clock is down to five
westbrook zips it to beale underneath
great look by westbrook as
bea was able to get for russ
facilitating finding brad i mean
threading the needle with that pass
and the rebound for westbrook
finding bertons running with the left of
the reverse
[Applause]
lopez great seal on justin holiday
and again the vision the awareness by
westbrook to see
if they can take advantage but lopez is
ducking in there's hutcheson in the
middle
there it is hutcheson flicks it up and
able to get it
in the first meeting back in march
they play three times as bertons hits
his second three of the game
run out for mcconnell and there's
gafford with the steal
westbrook back the other way looking for
hutcheson hutchison able to finish off
the feed by westbrook there's the eighth
assist already for russell westbrook
another steal hutchinson's got it this
time westbrook
numbers leaves it to gaffer gafford for
the dunk as you see
when the wizards get stops on the
defensive end brooke was going to go
to gafford and he still couldn't do
anything about it westbrook's got nine
assists the first two points for gafford
world record since april 3rd the only
team is playing better
these indiana pacers westbrook to
gafford
and gaffer just goes over sabonis
[Applause]
good defense by beal kept alive but
westbrook
rips the rebound down
leaves it for gafford for the big dunk
he just knows where to run to
being in the right place at the right
time and
finishing levert to answer
no westbrook up ahead beale
oh wow what a play russ
throwing that on the money but i like
what brad did he turned that into a
sumner gets the screen over len it's
long
here's westbrook hachimura running
there's the lob and there's the finish
[Applause]
westbrook tonetto underneath there's the
14th assist
keeping them above water right there on
that shot
hachimura left all alone along the
baseline
rui hancher is in double figures with
11.
one stuff that's historic and we're
seeing history in the making when it
comes to russell westbrook
there's the steal now tabitha finishes
with the dunk
edmund sumner with a left knee contusion
now questionable to return for indiana
already
under man then hot samora gets free for
another dunk
hachimura again that is the 19th
assist about what he was doing in the
first quarter he had like a double
double
the hook shot for lopez captain hook
returns
to russell westbrook afterwards and you
said just four more rebounds four more
rebounds
as he finds lopez there
hutcheson takes it away
finds west brook to hachimora a couple
of hot potato touch passes
[Applause]
westbrook the lob gafford the dunk
and there is a franchise tying
24th assist by russell westbrook
and this is what i'm talking about
people have to stay home
and with those shooters and daniel
gaffrey was rewarded on that play
at the rim
gafford's got 13 points tonight